hi this is Sadashiva PI from science
mission today we have a dr. iron mace
from ICANN School of Medicine at Mount
Sinai in New York
so he's the stem professor of
neuroscience and pharmacological
sciences there so dr. Mays has won
several awards to his credit
I'll name some of them in 2011 he got
very cruel which dissertation award from
Mount Sinai School of Medicine 2014 he
gave a couple of speeches as in West
United speaker in 2015 he one is MMS
nominees Searle Scholars Program nominee
in 2015 he won a travel award from
American College of
neuropsychopharmacology in 2015 he got
transforming mental health research
fellowship Wellcome Trust charity and
2015 again he won rod Rosen family this
is called a reward 2016 Alfred P sloan
Foundation research fellowship in
neuroscience and 2019
Harold golden Lampert award in basic
research it's an honor bestowed to an
outstanding junior faculty member at
Icahn School of Medicine at Mount Sinai
who shows exceptional potential for
making significant contributions over an
extended period of time in basic
research welcome dr. mace to science
hangout thank you for having me can you
please talk about yourself give some
information about your background your
education etc sure so I'm originally
from Columbus Ohio
I undergrad at the Ohio State University
majoring in microbiology and immunology
during my time there I actually did a
lot of undergrad research working in a
honeybee neurophysiology lab that then
got me interested kind of in
Oh science and so here I ended up after
I graduated moving to the University of
California San Francisco right was a
technician with Ulrika Hubbell I'm his
knowledge animal a farm after that time
I moved down to Dallas Texas and started
my PhD at the University of University
Texas Southwestern Medical Center in
Dallas my PhD advisor Erik Destler and
then when Eric moved to Mount Sinai to
become the director of the Friedman
Brain Institute I moved with him toward
the end of my PhD and finished my PhD
here okay and then after finishing my
PhD I moved down the street to
Rockefeller University where I did my
postdoctoral training with dr. C David
Alice was the original articulator of
the histone code hypothesis and then I
moved back here to Mount Sinai as an
assistant professor in 2014 ok and Apple
is about to add a lab that people etc
sure yeah so right now I have three
phenomenal postdocs one of whom is work
I'll be talking a lot about today I also
have four PhD students and a lab manager
as well as kind of rotating
undergraduate researchers that come
through typically in the summer so how
do you mentor them like what is you have
mentoring philosophy yeah I mean for me
I think the one thing I was really
trained to do early on starting with my
work with Erik Destler and then into
Dave Alice's lab was really you know
encouraging people to think big so
instead of just picking say your
favorite molecule and following that
molecule for the rest of your life I
really encourage people to you know look
at it from a 30,000 foot perspective be
willing to take risks in your work and
just to be passionate about it and so
you know I'd say I'm a pretty active
mentor I tend to like to meet with my
people as much as I possibly can given
travel schedules and so forth but yeah I
think really it's it for me and the
foundation it's just encouraging people
to think big take risks and be excited
about their science okay and other than
they said - what are you had hobbies
interests sure yeah so I mean I live in
New York City so
my family and I were very excited about
going to Broadway shows museums things
like that and also my wife and I are a
bit of white aficionados so okay that's
good and going back to research talk to
us about your projects and you can go
and present your work also sure yeah so
so when I started here at Mount Sinai
you know I was really trying to figure
out what my my niche would be right what
would set me potentially apart and
because I had done dual training in
molecular neurobiology and in chromatin
biochemistry I really let me down to a
path where I figured that if we could
somehow integrate those two more
faithfully than perhaps had been done
before that that would really open up
the door and so I think you know that my
lab philosophy is that we don't really
focus on a specific model system we do
study aspects of neurological disease
but we tend to let the very basic
chromatin biochemical mechanisms guide
us and so we have projects that range
from what I'll talk about today in terms
of the discovery of protein modern
mutilation or histone monomino Latian
all the way down to looking at models of
Down syndrome and drug abuse so you know
we're willing to kind of take risks in
all those different directions yeah so
you can't present - it'll shed the go
ahead here okay yeah all right great
okay so so as I mentioned so what I'm
gonna talk about today is some of the
work that my labs been involved in over
the past I guess you know four and a
half years now which is focusing on
alternative roles for linear hydrophobic
monoamine neurotransmitters so things
like serotonin dopamine histamine in the
central nervous system and so what we've
discovered I'll jump to the chase and
then all kind of backtrack and show you
how we got there we've essentially found
that numerous proteins in the brain
including histone proteins which are the
present wrap around our DNA can actually
form covalent bonds with these molecules
things like serotonin and they seem to
play a very important role in driving
everything from neural development to
plasticity and and of course they have
implications and disease
so I just want to start by saying that
you know none of this work occurs in a
vacuum so I have had the luck to work
with some of my my scientific heroes in
order to get this work done and I
definitely recommend to everyone that
they collaborate as extensively as
possible and so I'll be telling you
about work today and it's a really a
grand collaboration between my group and
with Lorna fairly postdoc in my lab
spearheading things and also Tamir who's
the chair of chemistry at Princeton
along with his postdocs Robert Thompson
and Kelly Chu and then also hi Talley is
a Chinua University in Beijing and his
student Xu is Xiao and of course there
are many other people and I'll show an
acknowledgement the end but we've also
worked with Bob Rader rusty gage Chris
Nevada Daria and many others okay so
just to get started so how did we kind
of get on to this so coming from a
background in neuroscience I've always
been of course interested in monoamine
neurotransmitters dopamine serotonin etc
and and you know when you think about
what these neurotransmitters do you have
to understand it when you look at
something like serotonin it plays a many
diverse roles throughout the body
everything from being a morphogen during
development to an auto Koide in the
periphery and then of course the way we
think about it is neuroscientists as a
the neurotransmitter in the central
nervous system and so the basic idea in
terms of how we think about these
molecules is that you have some neuronal
population let's say the dorsal raphe a
certain Uruk neurons that produce
serotonin that will ultimately release
serotonin which will traverse the
synaptic cleft and then bind to these
membrane bound receptors and ultimately
the way we would think about
neurotransmitters regulating say post
synaptic plasticity is that this
engagement of the postsynaptic receptors
then will lead to these kind of
complicated second messenger signaling
cascades that ultimately will converge
in the nucleus to mediate everything
from histone modifications to
transcription factor recruitment in
order to regulate gene expression that
can essentially fine-tune the plasticity
of those postsynaptic cells and so when
I was finishing my postdoc a paper came
out from Edwin Levinson at the
University of Pittsburgh which is here
this is from the journal
Sian's where they had a very interesting
finding that caught my eye so what they
were doing was they were using very
elegant to photon imaging to try to get
an estimate of how much of the serotonin
within a certain urge ignorant in the
end the brain is actually sequestered to
vesicles ready to be released a response
to a somatic stimulus and so when they
did this they actually to my surprise
found that only about 25% of all the
serotonin within a given search energy
neuron is sequestered to vesicles which
left this really large pool of extra
vesicular serotonin now also in this
paper they did some very nice photo
bleaching studies and in response to
stimulation and they found that not only
a serotonin present is this extra
vesicular form in the cytoplasm of these
cells but also within the nucleus of
these cells now to me this was really
really shocking so I started to dig
through the literature a bit and trying
to figure out were there other evidence
that these molecules could actually
exist in the nucleus and it turns out
that if you go back as as early as I
think 1971 saw Snyder Candace pert and
others had a beautiful paper in science
that was tracking histamine within the
cell body and the nucleus to cross the
mammalian brain development and they
actually found that almost all of the
histamine is sequestered to the nucleus
during early periods of embryonic brain
development and more recently there have
been some beautiful studies
invertebrates and vertebrates and
they've shown also very high levels of
nuclear serotonin pools now the idea in
this paper was simply that you know you
have prepackaged vesicles you receive a
stimulus you undergo somatic release and
you need to draw upon this reserve pool
of extra vesicular serotonin to
essentially replace the depleted
vesicular eyes pools so that's a very
straightforward idea and of course we
have observed in our hands in a variety
of systems that indeed serotonin
dopamine and others that we do see these
molecules within the nucleus so the
other paper that kind of caught my
attention after a conversation with a
colleague Olivier Burton was this one
this is a cell paper from 2003 from
Michael Bader's group at the max
delbruck in Berlin where they had shown
that in theory and I'll say I'll tell
you I in theory in a moment that
proteins could be trans
by a protein called the transglutaminase
or the transcript mas - enzyme to
actually form covalent bonds with
serotonin now the reason I say in theory
is that a lot of these earlier studies
were were performed in seed you so let's
say for example they wanted to look at
if proteins could be certain related in
platelets which don't produce serotonin
themselves but take it up from the
periphery what they would do is they
make lice aids from platelets
they basically purify a recombinant
transglutaminase they'd add radioactive
serotonin to the system and then they
basically IP for their favorite protein
and run autoradiography and when they
did this they did see that certain gtp
aces I think wrote gtp ace could indeed
undergo this process but again the
physiological relevance of this was
really I think still in question and
since 2003 there's been a lot of papers
that have tried to look I wouldn't say a
lot maybe 25 or so that have tried to
look at this process but they've always
kind of been stuck by looking at the in
vitro scenario so performing in vitro
reactions and just saying yes this can
happen but not a lot of functional
relevance described but in any case the
basic idea behind this mechanism is that
you have a donor amine containing
molecule in this case serotonin and you
have a glutamine containing substrate in
your protein and essentially in the
presence of the transglutaminase in
calcium because it's a calcium dependent
enzyme you can basically form a covalent
bond between the carboxy admit of the
glutamine and the donor amine of
serotonin to form this isoh peptide bond
between your substrate protein and the
donor serotonin molecule so that's the
basic premise so when I started my own
lab I wanted to get at this idea about
you know Ken cells do this on their own
right so instead of taking life's aids
or more common proteins Ken cells do
this on their own and so what we decided
to do based on some very nice literature
developing these types of probes is that
we decided to basically generate a
serotonin mimic so instead of having the
hydroxyl group off the aromatic ring
here you actually now have an alkyne
that's placed here and so this is called
pre populated we call it far away to
serotonin or 5pt
and the idea here was that if we could
synthesize this and put it into cells
say HeLa cells for example if it could
get into the cells we could then basic
we use copper click chemistry to attach
a bias in azide for example and then we
could immunoprecipitate out those biotin
label proteins and ask which proteins
can this endogenously happen to and so
what we did is after we basically pure
synthesize this molecule this is just
showing you some immunofluorescence from
HeLa cells where we've either added a
vehicle or the correlated serotonin and
then here we're using copper click
chemistry to click on an azide floor for
in this case a GFP type of label or a
green label and you can clearly see that
our property related serotonin can
actually get into the cells so after
this point we basically decided to
perform these large-scale screens after
immunoprecipitated the proteins that
theoretically are being serotonin lated
to ask what kind of proteins come out in
these screens and affordance we have
identified there are many different
proteins that appear to be putative
substrates for certain elation but as a
histone buff myself one of the things
that came out in our screens it was very
surprising is that histone h3 but none
of the other core öktem Erica stone so
h4 h-2a h-2b seem to be coming out as a
putative substrate for this modification
now as a person who does a lot of immuno
precipitations when you pull out
histones and these types of screens you
always get a little nervous because
they're highly basic and they tend to be
a little sticky but the fact that we saw
specificity for h3 gave us some you know
some some belief that perhaps this could
be real so we further delineated kind of
where the signal was coming forth coming
from for h3 so we actually then took
similar cells treated with vehicle or
party witness serotonin and we basically
fractionated them into cytosol like
soluble nuclear or chromatin bound
fractions and were able to find that our
signal was indeed actually coming from
the chromatin bound fraction so that was
encouraging but then to really get at
this question this all could be
nonspecific it could be that we pulled
out something bound to h3 and so we're
just getting h3 signal out so the next
step was to purify histone proteins and
directly ask the question can the
histones be mono amino lated so what we
decided to do is we purified histone h3
and histone h4 is a negative control we
also purified fibrinogen this is a
protein from the literature that's been
shown to be serotonin lated and we
performed assays where instead of using
serotonin we're actually using a
Makara moaning analog called model
danzel cadaverine this is really cool
because if it attaches to a protein you
can run a gel like the normal protein
gel but instead of transferring to a
membrane you can put it under UV light
like you do with DNA and you can see
your protein band so what we did here is
this is comparing basically in the
presence of the donor NBC minus and plus
the enzyme transglutaminase that indeed
are positive control we can get a nice
signal that h3 shows transamination and
that h4 does not and to take this a
little further for both fibrinogen and
h3 we also either added a inhibitor of
TG to sista mean where you lose the
signal or we were able to compete that
signal away with excess donor serotonin
so basically this was showing direct
evidence that histone h3 could be
serotonin ated okay so for people that
aren't as in the field of chromatin
biology as want to give a very quick
primer on on chromatin so as many people
were probably aware chromatin exists as
the physiological form of our genome so
obviously within the nucleus our DNA
which is meters long has to be packaged
in a way to fit into this small
compartment and the way that works is
that our DNA is wrapped around these
highly basic histone proteins so two
copies each of h3 h4 h 2a or h 2b and
they basically form what's called the
nucleosomes so this is about 147 base
pairs of DNA wrapped around in October
of the system proteins and this
basically will serve as the fundamental
repeating unit of transcription in all
eukaryotic cells so just from a semantic
standpoint there are many ways that
histones can be regulated actually I
just want to go back and point out that
within the nucleosome you of course have
your kind of globular domains but the
protruding outside of the nucleus ohm
you have what we call these tails
these are unstructured regions the
proteins and of course are heavily prone
to post translational modifications so
histones can be regulated in a variety
of ways in eukaryotic systems so one is
of course histone modifications which
I'll talk about almost exclusively today
also you can incorporate histone
variants which have small amino acid
substitutions which
in fact where they're deposited
throughout the genome and what their
functional impact is and then you also
have processes referred to as chromatin
remodeling so this is actually the
movement of histones along the DNA
template and this occurs through a
variety of very interesting mechanisms
so when we talk about histone
modifications we talked about a few
classes of associated proteins or
enzymes that that can interact with
these modifications so one we have our
proteins that we refer to as writers so
these are the enzymes that can actually
put on the histone modification of
interest we have proteins we refer to as
erasers that actually remove them and
then we have these proteins are very
interesting called readers that
specialized functional domains that
actually interact in a very tight
fashion with these modifications to kind
of promote the transcriptional outputs
okay okay so so now I'm going back to
the fact that we've now found that
histone h3 seems to be a putative
substrate that recombinant lee it can be
modified in this way the first thing we
want to do is kind of get back at this
question about the writer enzyme so what
is actually able to put it on so as I
mentioned in that first paper from
Michael Bay term at in 2003 they had
suggested that a ubiquitous Lee Express
protein called the tissue
transglutaminase to enzyme could serve
as the substrate for this modification
so we started by basically performing
simple assays again in our party latest
serotonin system in HeLa cells where we
either added vehicle are prepared early
to serotonin or prepare diluted
serotonin with an inhibitor of the
transglutaminase and then again
performed our immuno precipitations with
blotting for h3 to ask what impact is
inhibiting TG do you have on this
process and so you can clearly see here
that we can IP h3 very efficiently but
in the presence of TG to inhibition you
essentially lose all of that binding now
this kind of shows that T g2 is
necessary but how about is it actually
sufficient to promote this type of
process so we have kind of one thing I
found early on it was kind of surprising
is that when you compare two very common
tissue culture cell lines heck - 93 T
cells and HeLa cells which I've been
focusing on we actually find that T G -
whereas it's expressed very highly in
HeLa cells is not expressed at all in
heck - 93 T cells so this gave us an
opportunity where we could potentially
add back
tgd to to heck cells and see if a system
that normally shouldn't be able to do
this now Ken and so that's essentially
what we're showing here so again this is
of course without any transfection we
are not able to see any full down of h3
with our correlated serotonin however if
we add back a wild-type form of tg2 we
are able to immunoprecipitate h3 so
showing that we can basically add back
this process and if we incorporate a TG
- that actually is catalytically dead we
now lose that process so it does show
both a necessary and an argument for
sufficiency and of course we've also now
performed you know direct assays so
originally when I told you about the MDC
assays we've also performed direct
search on wet so it says who's being
searched for Malaysian assays using
radioactive serotonin where again we're
able to show the same basic effect which
is that our positive control can be
certain related whereas it can be
inhibited by system een BSA as a
negative control cannot be H 3 can be H
4 cannot be and more importantly if we
reconstitute nucleosomes in vitro so a
more physiologically relevant context
again we can see that we can very nicely
circulate nucleosomes and compete that
away with an inhibitor of TG 2 so this
is all fine and good but now we need to
know where is the site where is it
happening is it you know there are eight
glutamine is present in h3 so the
question is where does it actually
happened so what we did is we performed
a lot of in vitro transient trans
imitation reactions on histones
performed mass spectrometry and in doing
so we're able to find that essentially
one glutamine residue which is found in
the far in terminal tail of page 3 this
is a position 5 starting from the in
terminus that this glutamine 5 seems to
be the dominant site of histone
acetylation and we're able to show that
if we actually mutate that site to an
alanine and re perform our model Denzil
cadaverine assays that indeed we lose
much of that signal ok ok so now we have
a site so what do you do in the
chromatin field you make an antibody
right now there's a couple things I want
to point out before I kind of go through
this so again this is looking at the h3
sequence from the interest C terminus
this is our glutamine that gets
serotonin elated but of course for
anyone who studies chromatin in any
context you know that the adjacent
lysine at position 4 can be mono di and
tri methyl
and the try methylated state of k4 is of
course incredibly important for
recruitment of the general transcription
factors that allow for transcriptional
initiation okay so this got us thinking
you know when we started building our
tools we originally were gonna make an
antibody just to recognize q5 sera tonal
but then I thought to myself what about
if we also made one that recognized the
combinatorial state of both k4
trimethylation tonal this would give us
some idea about whether or not there's
going to be a common twirl role for
these modifications so I won't go into
this into any depth but we did make both
antibodies we've tested them in a
variety of scenarios both in vitro and
in vivo and we can see that both of our
antibodies are total alone of course
recognized the serotonin late state or
unmodified and this is just showing you
that our dual antibody also does not
cross react for example with k4
trimethylation the santa body's we've
also gone back in vivo into both search
nergic cells which I'll talk about a
little bit and also into the rodent
brain and now performing mass
spectrometry we're able to actually see
that these modifications exists in vivo
so this is now showing you basically a
trace where we're tracking the
endogenous peptide so this is where the
K 4 is going to be tri methylated in the
q5 is Sarah tonal ated and this is where
we're spiking in a synthetic peptide
that we made in vitro and clearly you
can see that you are actually able to
pull up essentially a mirror image so we
are able to see that this modification
exists in vivo and that's of course
always very important I think in these
types of studies the other thing is that
we wanted to test the dependency of
whether the enzymes that put on sera
correlation or that put on k4
trimethylation is their first and so to
do this again with Tom Muir and Rob
Thompson we were able to make different
types of nucleosomes so we were able to
make nucleosomes that were homogenous
for h3k4 trimethylation us for h3q5
serotonin so this can all be done in
vitro using express protein ligation we
were able to make octamer and then
nucleosomes and basically perform these
reactions in vitro and say for example
if the nucleosomes are k4 trimethylation
does tg2 care
about that can still serotonin relate
the nucleosome or not and what we found
is that it really doesn't seem to care
at all
so if k4 trimethylation relate the
adjacent glutamate the other reverse
scenario is whether or not complexes
like the ML l1 complex would put on k4
does it care if the serotonin was there
and the answer of course is no so it
does seem that they can really
potentially not only do we have mass
spec evidence that they can exist in
vivo together but we also of course have
in feature evidence showing that the
enzymes that put them on don't seem to
mine okay so now that we have these
antibodies we've test them the variety
of systems we started with a very basic
question which is that one you know are
these marks evolutionarily conserved and
then - where are they throughout the
body so now this is going to be using
this as blots for h3k4 trimethylation
also the combinatorial state and here
we're actually looking across a variety
of organisms that produce serotonin so
Drosophila melanogaster the mouse this
is a bonnet macaque monkey and the human
and we basically see that the mark
exists in all these scenarios but if you
look it's not shown here if you look in
yeast for example which don't produce
serotonin you don't see any signal okay
now what's really surprising is that
when you start to look across the organs
you know you see that there's of course
a lot of brain enrichment that makes
sense the serotonin is produced in the
brain we see a lot of signal in the
colon this makes sense because most of
our peripheral serotonin is making the
colon and we also see some expression
and all the other tissues so it's it's
weakened the lung and the liver but
there's some there we see a little more
in the heart although I suspect that a
lot of that signal comes from blood
contaminating blood but I think the most
shocking part is that when we looked
across the brain I fully anticipated
that we would only see the mark occur
within brain regions that produce
serotonin the dorsal raphe nucleus for
example but it actually turns out that
you see the serotonin signal across all
brain regions and we've now even gone
further to sort out neurons and glia
from these different brain regions and
we find that it's in all the different
cells which of course begs many
questions about how is it getting there
is this something that's super early
developmentally established or is there
actually a system where you can uptake
serotonin into postsynaptic brain
regions and we can chat about that
toward the end
okay so the next question is where where
is it in the genome right is this
something that is going to be basically
promoting h3k4 trimethylation is it
going to be at permissive or active
genes or is this something that's going
to be antagonistic and to be honest when
I went into this these experiments I
fully believed that this mark was going
to be antagonistic I thought that if you
put a bulky hydrophobic molecule next to
this lysine that needs to recruit these
proteins and this surely is going to
kick those proteins off and it's going
to be a repressive modification so we
decided to look at this in a variety of
systems so the first system we looked at
this was in collaboration with rusty
gage and Chris Nevada Daria out in Salk
Institute we wanted to look in human
neurons human serotonergic neurons and
we wanted to track as you differentiate
plural human pluripotent stem cells to
serotonergic neurons in vitro what
happens to the mark do you elevate the
signal and if so where does it actually
go and so this is just some bright field
images showing that indeed of course we
can differentiate neurons from these
Corre potent stem cells we performed a
lot of IH t nif analysis to just make
sure that indeed we are making a
relatively pure population of search
nergic neurons we estimate that about 80
percent from each of these lines are
actually searching our cheek neurons and
then taking these cells we just started
simply by blotting comparing pluripotent
stem cells to neurons for both k4
trimethylation now in this case we see
that both the k4 trimethylsilyl
modification show really dramatic
increases in response to differentiation
into serotonergic neurons although
perhaps there's a significant increase
in the serotonin over that of k4
trimethylamine and so we decided that
okay well since we get such a robust
increase this gives a good system where
we can perform chip C using our h3k4
trimethylation antibody and ask where is
it going and how does it relate to
transcriptional outputs related to
differentiation so we performed shift
seek again in the pluripotent stem cells
and neurons again this is just looking
at the total number of Peaks called so
you see that you dramatically increase
the number of Peaks which makes sense
because you're dramatically increasing
the amount of the mark we then tracked
where in the genome you actually see
these modifications occurring of course
they predominantly occurred
the promoter and again we're able to
validate that most of these events in
the promoter are increased enrichment
events and this is just showing you kind
of a sample track so this is a neuron
Express gene lvl3 you can see clearly
that the mark is coming on around the
transcriptional start site of this gene
and if you look at another protein that
say only expressed in a pluripotent stem
cells like nanog you don't see any of
this increased enrichment so the kind of
started to indicate that contrary to my
expectations that perhaps this
modification could be permissive to
transcription and so what we did then is
we performed what are called odds ratio
analysis or a Fisher exact test where we
can overlap our RNA seek data so looking
at genes that show increased or
decreased expression in response to
differentiation and overlap those would
show either increased or decreased
enrichment of the mark and what we find
it's not it's not a hundred percent but
we find that the strongest correlation
is that increased enrichment of the
modification seems to correlate most
strongly with increased expression of
these genes okay but it's not an
all-or-none scenario so to validate this
assumption we now move to the embryonic
mouse brain during development where
again we can track scenarios where if
you look at a early in embryonic
development and be nine point five
versus seventeen point five so this is a
time period in which Surgenor chick
neurons in the brain develop and start
to basically promote long-range
projections this is also a time when you
can see that tph 2 which is the enzyme
that basically is producing serotonin
that indeed we get elevation of the of
this marker and just like in the human
neurons we see that as you go from e 9.5
be 17.5 in the mouse brain during
development
then both k4 tri methyl and the k4
trimethylation 'el are both increased in
their enrichment okay so next performing
chip seek again now for k4 tri methyl
and our dual modification we again find
very high levels in the more developed
embryonic brain we also see that most of
this is coming from the promoters and
that many of these events are increased
enrichment events and what's really
interesting here is that when you
correlate to gene expression throughout
the course of development now we're able
to see very strong associations with
gene expression so in this case you see
that
that are going to be increased
expression are the ones that show
increased enrichment of the mark and
those that are reducing their expression
throughout development are showing
decreased enrichment of the mark M genes
that are changed there's basically no
significant Association now the problem
that's very exciting that's very
promising but the problem with these
studies is that they don't distinguish
between k4 tri methyl and k4
trimethylation tonal if you overlap
where these differential agreement
events occur you basically see that the
overlap is almost 100% between the two
marks so it was still giving us some
trouble about how do we really show that
the serotonin mark is permissive and
it's not being driven solely by h3k4
trimethylation Orang 46 a b 14 cell
system so this is a rat medullary
blastoma cell line that was taken from
the ventral midbrain during rat
development so it was taken right before
surgery neurons start to develop it was
then immortalized and then they staple e
transfected it with the brain derived
neurotrophic factor BDNF now what's cool
about this system is that they basically
are proliferating cells because they're
transformed they do produce some
serotonin but if you basically put them
under heat shock conditions because of
the BDNF being expressed they actually
start to basically they become post
mitotic they produce a ton more
serotonin and they start to form in all
right so they become more neuronal light
now what was cool about this is that
when we looked again at our h3k4
trimethylation all we were able to see
that it's increase in its expression
during differentiation so just like we
saw in our human neurons and mouse brain
but when we looked at h3k4
trimethylation here it doesn't change at
all so it was just a it was flat so we
thought okay this is perfect we now have
a system where k4 trimethylation will
mark does now we can maybe show that the
serotonin mark is doing something to
change expression irrespective of k4
trimethyl so again an undifferentiated
versus differentiated cells we perform
chip seat for k4 trimethylamine called
versus the dual serotonin mark where we
are seeing this increase and we're able
to then correlate this back to gene
expression to ask what is the
correlation and the absence of changes
with a streak a for tri methyl it's
and again we're able to show the
correlation is incredibly strong and
positive so increased gene expression
increased enrichment decreased gene
expression decreased enrichment so this
gives us a lot of confidence that h3k4
trimethylation teed permissive and
there's some other interesting things we
did just to look at you know what what
happens if you start to manipulate the
sort of tonal mark in these cells so
again we use the R in 46 cells pretty
much because they're easier to work with
than everything else we were doing and
what we decided to do here is basically
take these cells so this is
undifferentiated State this is now RNA
sequencing data and so looking at gene
expression we also took these cells and
during differentiation over expressed
wild-type is 3.3 or h-street protein
which can be certain related and we also
in another set expressed the east 3.3
where that glutamine has been converted
to an alanine so it can be saram related
it acts essentially as a dominant
negative so it will reduce the ability
to it will reduce the ability to induce
that modification during differentiation
and when you do this what you see is
that by basically limiting the amount of
search in relation in these Sidney cells
during differentiation that from the RNA
sneak standpoint they're actually
starting to convert back to what looks
like more of an undifferentiated State
from a transcriptional standpoint if we
inhibit TG 2 we get a very similar
effect to what we're actually seeing
with the q5 a as predicted so again
another way to reduce the modification
and what's really interesting is that
when you add this q5 a to compete away
the serotonin work you actually force
the cells into a more undifferentiated
State so here we're looking at the full
difference in neurite outgrowth and
essentially when they can't serotonin
elite during differentiation you're
reducing the overall neurite outgrowth
so we have a feeling we still need to
show this I think in different systems
but we have a feeling that not only is
this mark being established to promote
permissive gene expression but if you
aberrantly inhibited that you'll block
the differentiation state where you'll
least reduce it okay so we've gotten to
the point of no I think unambiguously
showing that this modification exists
showing that TG 2 is indeed the enzyme
that writes this modification
all the way to showing that it seems to
associate or correlate with permissive
chain expression
so the next question is how could it do
that right I told you at the beginning
that I was convinced that if you put
this bulky hydrophobic molecule next to
k4 you're gonna kick off everything that
normally binds to it so to get at this
what we decided to do is basically
synthesize histone tail peptide so the
far in terminal tail of h3 put a biotin
tag onto it and then we basically
chemically modified them in a variety of
ways so we had four different types of
bias and labeled histone tail peptides
either unmodified key for tri methylated
q v serotonin aidid or those that had
the dual mark that we're looking at we
then basically can add art we can
conjugate our biotin label peptides
district avidin beads we can stick them
into nuclear extracts of our choice in
this case we just started with HeLa
soluble nuclear extracts and then
essentially using streptavidin you
immunoprecipitate out your peptide
protein complexes and perform mass
spectrometry to ask what comes down with
these marks and how are they affected
under the different states and so in
doing that we saw some really
interesting things so first thing we did
is we compared h3k4 trimethylation tries
modification we knew what we should be
finding and long story short we found
all the binders that everyone has always
found so that gave us a lot of a sense
of security that we were doing the right
thing the next thing we did is we asked
of these k4 binders this is a volcano
class showing all of the issue key for
tri tri methyl binders we asked what
does the impact of q 5 search all have
on these interactions so everything in
gray or k4 trimethylation modified that
are not changed by the presence of the
serotonin mark the things in red are the
things that are either increased or
decreased and their overall enrichment
or binding by the serotonin mark and
then very surprisingly you can see
there's a lot of things attenuated a
number of things potentiated but
surprisingly we pulled out basically the
entire general transcription factor
complex tf2d as showing an increased
binding in the presence of the dual
serotonin mark versus k4 trim level and
this again very surprising to me we
validated that tf2d
subunits are actually increased in their
binding so this is now performing
peptide IPS from the extracts and blots
you can clearly see that for every
subunit we looked at cap
the TVP or tata binding protein and all
the associated tasks that indeed
compared to k4 tri methyl when you add
the serotonin you dramatically increase
the amount being pulled down and this is
just quantified here
we've also showed that if you purify the
TM to be complex itself so in this case
we're basically using a flag tagged tbp
expressing HeLa cell line where we can
purify tbp that comes down with all the
tasks and again on a purified complex we
again can show that in every case the
binding is stronger when you have the
Saratov mark in conjunction with h3k4
trimethylation that is well okay that's
fine and good but what what is causing
that so in this figure I'm showing you
that all of them are showing increased
binding so what in this protein complex
could actually be facilitating this
increased interaction so there is one
protein within this in this complex
that's called tap three and tap three
has a plant homeo domain one of these
really dimensions that is already known
to be a very strong interactor with h3k4
trimethylation already is known to bind
a key for trimethyl maybe somehow it's
been influenced in its interaction by
the presence of q5 search model so the
first thing we did is we actually
purified the plant and homeodomain of
tap 3 so purify 2 recombinant protein
and we decided to perform isothermal
titration calorimetry where we could
test directly the interaction between
the PhD finger of 1/2 3 and our
different modified or unmodified histone
tail peptides so this is what you're
looking at here these are the ITC traces
the most important thing to look at is
the KD
so remember KD the lower the KD the
higher the binding right and so you can
see here that when you just look at your
k4 modified States you see an increase
as you go from unmodified so 21 micro
molar to mono to a mono methylated 1.8 1
micromolar to die methylated and tri
methylated you see huge increases in
binding this is what's been shown before
in the literature but what was really
surprising is that when you look at say
unmodified versus certain elated or in
any of the methylated states with the
serotonin we
able to see basically increased binding
and if you look at the difference
between say k4 tri methyl and our dual
sera tonal with k4 trimethylation
increase in binding overall so this
supports the idea that taffy itself may
be driving some of this increased
recruitment so with our collaborator at
Tsinghua University they were able to
actually solve the crystal structure for
the interaction between this k4
trimethylation histone peptide and the
tap free plant homeodomain that
definitely assured us that they do
interact directly so they're not kicking
each other off but the unfortunate thing
was we actually traced the electron
density we didn't get good electron
density around the serotonin molecule so
the reason for this is likely that you
know k4 trimethylamine pocket the q5
stereo tunnel is probably out on the
surface and it's relatively flexible so
it's moving around it may be promoting
some kind of affinity effect but it's
not directly sinking into the pocket to
promote this increased interaction so
high tau and all of our colleagues
perform some beautiful follow-up
experiments to try to figure this out a
little more so in this case they
actually performed NMR spectroscopy
which allows us to look at chemical
shifts based on heavy labelled
nitrogen's in the top free protein
between our k4 trimethylamine state and
you can of course see here just by
looking at the two states that there are
many amino acids that show pretty large
chemical shifts and using these data you
can then model with the what the
structure would likely be and so long
story short what we think is happening
is that normally these trip to fans
right around the h3k4 trimethylation to
a binding pocket normally they form
basically an aromatic cage so they're
kind of in closing the k4 trimethylation
the structure and what we think happens
is is when you add this Q 5 stereo total
you're in essence increasing the
affinity with that with that aromatic
cage or actually completing that
aromatic cage and so our current
hypothesis is that this is how this is
working and we're now performing a
number of mutational studies to figure
out if this is really the case but I
think in any case we now know that a3 is
a direct interactor and it shows
potentiate interactions in the presence
of sera Malaysia so the current model
before I go on to the
part which is shorter is that
essentially you know you have during
development you have your normal
patterns of transcriptional regulation
by h3k4 trimethylation this of course
causes recruitment of reader proteins in
particular the pre-initiation complex to
promote normal permissive transcription
during development however in certain
cells in the body you also will have the
ability to transaminase with serotonin
these k4 trimethylation sites that we
think that this is going to increase the
recruitment of these reader proteins and
in particular T of 2 D and this will
potentiate transcription throughout
developer now the question though of
course is it you know if this is the
case that it's driving the enhancement
of gene expression would it also have an
effect on the ability to remove h3k4
trimethylation k4 trimethylation
development it needs to stay there
because once genes are on you need those
genes they may need to be fine-tuned but
you ultimately want them to be on so we
started test this idea that maybe the d
methylase is to take off k4 are gonna
have problems interacting with that
modification in the presence of the
serotonin so getting back to my original
idea that maybe it kicks things off so
we tested this in a variety of ways so
the first thing we did is perform multi
tock mass spectrometry so in this case
we started with either a k4 tri methyl
peptide or we started with a k4
trimethylation apep time and we
performed recombinant histone
demethylation reactions so in this case
we're using a purified KTM phi b which
takes off h3k4 trimethylation tunnel
there does it impact the ability to
demethylate the k4
so you can see on the normal k4 peptide
that you can demethylate it very rapidly
so by the time you get to four hours
most of its unmodified some of the
smaller methylated but when you look at
the serrator elated peptide its stalling
out in the time in the
dimethyl aidid state okay so it implied
that maybe having the search on there
can block this interaction but to take
this the next step Tamir who basically
makes what's called designer of
chromatin it's really a beautiful
process they essentially decided that
they were going to make nucleosomes who
were modified in these different ways so
oligo nucleosomes where they would
either be homogeneously issue k4
trimethylation
or homogeneously dually modified with
both the tri methyl in the Saratov mark
and they decided to perform
demethylation reactions on the
nucleosomes themselves because it's more
bio physically relevant now in this case
we're looking at the production of h3k4
monomethylation of the tri methyl state
so tri methyl 2 mono methyl so clearly
you can see that when you perform these
reactions on k4 trimethylation
nucleosomes do you very quickly
demethylate them but what's really
amazing is that when you have the
serotonin in the context of nucleosomes
it completely eliminates all
demethylation taking this one step
further we can test a dependency of
within the D methylases their own plant
homeo domains which normally bind to
adjacent unmodified nucleosomes that
stimulate their activity on the
nucleosomes of interest so what they did
here is they made all of these different
sets I'll take you through it very
carefully so we either have nucleosomes
where you have k4 trimethylation and the
adjacent new whose ohm is unmodified and
this is an oligo nucleosome you have
somewhere it's k4 trimethylation but the
adjacent nucleosome the tail has
actually been cleaved so the PhD finger
that normally binds to it to stimulate
its activity no longer reveal to
stimulate its activity we have some
where we decided to put k4 tri methyl
you CLE as ohms so asking the question
do they need to be together where can
they be
just adjacent to one another and then we
also made the Dooley modified state
again with the adjacent fulling tail or
the truncated tail so there are two
major points to this figure so the first
major point is that we were able to show
the dependency of that PhD finger to
stimulate the activity of this D methyl
a so this is now showing basically this
situation so if k4 is tri methylated and
then then adjacent nucleosome is
unmodified that you get your normal
demethylation but if you truncate that
adjacent nuclear zone you lose it right
or you're reducing the signal but again
when you have sera translation there
it's completely gone so this implies
that the PhD finger itself which
stimulates the activity of demethylases
cannot overcome the antagonism by the
serotonin mark and then interesting that
the last point is is that if you put
serotonin and the KFOR on it
nucleosomes so they're not together like
here if you put them adjacently you can
still demethylate so it implies that
they really do have to be literally
right next to one another and then the
final experiment here was that we
actually looked at this in a
physiologically relevant context where
they performed or generated
oligonucleotide well substrates are k4
trimethylation or duly modified then
then biotin labeled them and we stuck
them into nuclear extracts where there
are t methylases present pulled them out
and asked the question what is the
impact of these marks and again in a
more in vivo like scenario k4
trimethylation by dipping into extracts
with a newly modified state cannot and
so the way that we think this works is
that normally these demethylases so this
is a larger family family of
demethylases that take off k4
trimethylation methylases there's a
conserved aspartic acid residue at this
position here at 312 and normally what
we find is that this aspartic acid
actually forms a hydrogen bond with the
glutamine the gifts mono amino lated
therefore if you Sarah totally that
glutamine no longer can DD methylase
interact with the glutamine and
therefore you get steric hindrance and
it causes the demethylase to kick off so
now we have this kind of larger scenario
where the press the dual presence of k4
and q5 Saratov not only potentiates the
recruitment of things that promote
permissive expression it also kicks off
things that prevent the expression okay
and so I'll go through this part very
quickly but I just want to mention I've
been talking a lot about these common
toriel States but I do want to point out
that we have evidence that q5 serotonin
can exist also in the absence of k4 tri
methyl so we have both mass spectrometry
data to this effect in cells and search
nergic cells and we've also performed
chips sequencing with q5 sewer tunnel in
our own 46 cells during differentiation
now what's really interesting about this
is that when we compare genes that are
say induced in their expression during
differentiation versus those that are
repressed or unchanged we of course see
the q5 sir atonal can see the mark as a
transcriptional start sites probably in
conjunction with k4 trimethylation the
gene bodies and this is surprising
because the dual
vacation does not show up in the G
bodies not only does it show up in the
gene bodies but it seems to enrich quite
heavily along exons and so this type of
exonic enrichment looks a lot like
another histone modification hpk 36 try
methyl which is one of these interesting
modifications that's both involved in
alternative splicing and also is a
repressive modification with inactive
genes and that's essentially kind of
what we think may be happening here okay
so now we want to test that a little bit
further so again going back to our
peptide peak experiments we wanted to
now compare q5 serotonin binders so no
more k4 versus unmodified and say are
they the same binders that bind when k4
trimethylation and the answer is no h3q5
share a total outside the context of k4
trimethylation we find in gene bodies at
exons recruits two different complexes
one is the spliceosome so I just
mentioned very interesting that we see
this pure exonic enrichment so the fact
that we're pulling out a lot of the
spliceosome is potentially interesting
and also we pull out the repressive nerd
complex again perhaps supporting the
idea that if you q5 serotonin late
histones within gene bodies and
permissive genes that maybe you're
controlling a repressive response within
highly expressed genes and I'll come
back to that in just a moment the other
thing of course it's interesting given
the fact that we recruit the nerd
complex which contains a lot of DNA
methyl binding proteins the MB DS we
also wanted to check and see what is the
impact of q50 tunnel on the DNA
methyltransferases themselves because as
you may know DNA methylation within the
gene bodies of active chains is also
thought to be repressive to control
rates of transcriptions of highly
expressed genes so we tested this in a
variety of ways again performing peptide
peas and blotting for things like dnmt3a
3b and 3l where essentially we find that
it the presence of q5 serotonin does not
seem to impede the binding versus
unmodified and again with shuozhou and
high Tali we're able to solve the
crystal structure for this interaction
so this is now the EDD domain of dnmt3a
so this is part of what allows for its
binding to histone proteins and there's
this really cool effect where normally
within the presence of sand
modified histone tail this glutamic acid
and this arginine form a hydrogen bond
but when you insert the q5 serotonin
even though it's not overall affecting
the bindings it causes this arginine to
kick well outside of the pocket and you
form new hydrogen bonds with the
serotonin molecule itself so for us this
provided some thoughts that maybe the
presence of the serotonin would actually
allosteric ly regulate the activities of
that protein and so that's exactly what
we find so this is now purifying either
dnmt3a directly or the dnmt3a 3l complex
and performing peptide spike in assays
so the idea here is that if you test
dnmt3a activity or methylation capacity
on a unmodified substrate a cg rich
substrate if you spike in an unmodified
histone tail it actually increases
dnmt3a activity and this has been shown
before
if you spike in a k4 trimethylation
peptide you don't see that increase in
activity but much to our surprise but in
enjoyment we found that if you spike in
the q5 surge normal peptide either with
the full of dnmt3a or the complex you
dramatically increase the activity of
dnmt3a so we have this kind of working
model we still have much work to do on
this which is that perhaps what's
happening is that q5 serotonin gets
deposited along exons and highly
expressed genes that this does not
perturb the ability but instead
stimulates the activity of dnmt3a triela
to lay down DNA methylation within these
genes simultaneously you get recruitment
of the nerd complex which will stabilize
the binding of the DNA methylation and
so the thought is is that maybe this
basically restricts cryptic or
inappropriate gene expression within
those highly expressed genes but this is
something that we have to figure out and
so just to end in the last few minutes
here I just wanted to talk about the big
picture so we've done a lot of work with
sarin relation we have a lot of ongoing
work in that area but I want to point
out that we now have mass spec evidence
for the existence of all the other of
linear hydrophobic mono means so we know
that histones can also be dopamine
elated aq5 norepinephrine histamine
elated okay even trace amines like
tryptamine tyramine octo be mean they
all can do this and what's really cool
and this is something that my used to my
students Asha Fulton is working on non
endogenous hydrophobic amino
can also transmit a protein it's not
necessarily histones but they can
transaminase proteins and feta mean
being one example now to me this is just
I know kind of scary you think about all
the drugs that are on the market for a
variety of scenarios and you know we
think about them working through these
receptor ligand interactions but is it
possible that certain types of molecules
actually directly monomial eight
proteins in our body to regulate their
function so that's you know more more to
come on that and I don't want to go
through this any detail other than to
say that we're now looking at this in a
lot of in vivo context so my student
actually he pack has a beautiful story
and revision and science right now which
is focused on how histone dopamine
elation and the dopaminergic neurons in
the ventral tegmental area how they're
affected by exposure to drugs of abuse
like cocaine heroin et cetera where she
sees that not only does withdrawal from
chronic drug administration lead to
significant increases these marks that
we inhibit these increases we can block
relapse vulnerability so I think this is
a very exciting frontier a very
different role for dopamine in the
context of drug abuse we're also of
course looking at things like histones
certain relation in the context of
stress you know the regulation by
antidepressants where again we can see
that for example animals that have
undergone chronic stress and withdrawal
from that stress so increases in these
certain remarks antidepressants can
reverse these types of responses that we
can mimic that through mutational
studies in vivo all the way down to
looking at histamine elation and the
tubero mammillary nucleus this is Rian
vassals work in my lab this shows that
this mark unlike the others cycles in a
perfect circuit Ian's pattern in this
brain region and this is really cool
because it also implies to me that there
must be an active mechanism to remove
these marks which is something that we
still are pretty unclear about and we
have a really cool mechanism that I
won't go into and so the final question
of course is where do we go from here
you know I'm obviously a histone fanatic
but you know bond amines are all over
the cell they're very important for a
variety of functions in the nervous
system so the question was are there
actually additional substrates of mono
mutilation in the brain and what could
they potentially be doing so again now
in collaboration with Rob Thomson and
Tom mirror they were able to help us
develop a
probe a chemical probe that will allow
us to basically click on this probe that
will be biased and tagged to any
endogenously dopamine elated substrate
so any protein no matter what
compartment in the brain that's dope
mutilated we can put our probe in it'll
allow us to basically pull out these
proteins and then test for functional
significance so now using this probe
this is just an example we obviously
started by looking at the dopaminergic
brain region the ventral tegmental area
we've made nuclear lice aids and of
course we wanted to look for our protein
that we know gets don't mutilated which
is h3 and we test it and you can clearly
see that when we use our probe we pull
out a lot of endogenous like dopamine
related h3 so that was a good control
but since that time Ryan and Andrew
Stewart my lab has done a lot of nice
work to sort out either a VTA
nuclei and other compartments to try to
run mass spec screens and figure out
what's being regulated we've got lots of
very interesting targets a lot of them
chromatin associated things that
regulate transcription so one example is
this protein crest it's part of the
neuronal swai sniff chromatin remodeling
complex it's heavily glutamine rich and
it also is being dopamine elated so
that's an interesting target were
looking at but taking it further than
that I think for most neuroscientists
who think about these things at the
synapse we also wanted to test to see
what could be potentially dopamine
elated at dopaminergic synapses so in
this case what we did is we went to the
region of the brain one of the regions
of the brain the nucleus accumbens that
receives projections from those
dopaminergic neurons we actually make
synaptic neurons neural preps so we
enrich for synaptic proteins as shown
here and then again we performed our
dopamine or probe experiments to say are
there synaptic proteins to get dopamine
elated now taking that further not only
do we want to see if there are just
endogenous substrates we want to see how
those substrates are regulated by things
that regulate dopamine signaling so in
this case for example we put animals to
heroin self administration this is
something that will dramatically affect
dopamine release dynamics and then we
compared the binding profiles of the
original profiles of dopamine related
proteins between control and heroin
self-administering animals now this is
probably hard to see but you can see of
course we pulled out hundreds of
putative substrates for dopamine elation
both in the VTA nuclei and also the
nucleus accumbens synapse but you can
see this is one example there are also
many proteins that show elevated
dopamine elation in the nucleus
accumbens synapse in response to heroin
self administration so that's definitely
very interesting and one of those
proteins that really has caught our eye
and we're studying a lot these days is
this protein called kim kinase to gamma
now i'm sure everyone's familiar with
the camp kinases but cam kinase to gamma
in the brain serves a very interesting
role so cam kinase to gamma can be
phosphorylated by camp minus 2 beta at
the synapse okay in response to l-type
calcium channel signaling cam kinase 2
gamma once it's phosphorylated also can
then shuttle its way to the nucleus
carrying calmodulin with it okay to
activate the signaling cascade that
ultimately promotes CREB transcription
which is incredibly important for
activity dependent or immediate early
gene expression etc so we were really
excited that maybe the dopamine the
hyper dopamine elation of Kim Chi nice
to be Emma in the response to heroin
self administration then maybe this
could be influencing that state or that
shuttling so the first thing we needed
to do is figure out where in the world
as a being dopamine elated so again we
go back to our classic approach we
purify cam kinase to gamma we perform
our in vitro certain elation assays and
we ask where it is and what we found was
supercool to me is that there's only one
glutamate and this entire protein that's
being dopamine elated it's at position
285 which sits in the calcium calmodulin
binding domain and of course that
phosphor ban theanine that gets
phosphorylated that causes it to showing
to the nucleus it's only two amino acids
away so this really makes me think if
you don't let me know like this are you
gonna influence the ability to
phosphorylate are you going to increase
or reduce it what does the impact going
to be and so this is something now we're
devoting a lot of time to so I think
clearly there is an enormous amount to
be done you know we're very excited
about this we know kind of the initial
discovery we're still trying to figure
out if things take it off we're still
trying to figure out better methods to
allow us to look at these things in vivo
to manipulate them in vivo I just want
to point out one thing before I showed
the acknowledgments which is that in
collaboration with the ILO David is a
brilliant new professor at
sloan-kettering just down the street
that we've been using this novel
approach of in team chemistry
go into too many details but the idea is
that we can use this chemistry to
essentially allow us to generate de novo
in living cells in this case this is
actually in the brain we can generate
modified histones the goal being if we
wanted to test for example does increase
dopamine elation and the VTA neurons
does it actually promote drug
vulnerability would it be great if we
get to novo synthesize it when animals
have gone through self administration
promoted and see if we can potentiate
these types of behaviors and
transcriptional responses and so this is
something that we're very very excited
about and so so on that of course I'm
happy to take your questions that this
was unfortunately a failed cover
illustration that we did for for our
nature paper I thought it was pretty
clever this was done by alexey shows now
this is a king in Queens a lysine and
glutamine you can see the tripartite
fleur-de-lis for Kate for tri methyl in
our our serotonin like flowers here and
anyways I just want to basically thank
everybody that has done this work again
none of this work happens in a vacuum my
lab is amazing my collaborators are
phenomenal and of course I've had to
receive a lot of funding in order to
carry out this work so on that I will
end and take the questions okay okay
yep oh you can see I can see myself yeah
okay it's a really interesting work I
mean like initially you talk a lot of
stuff on the field by chemists part of
it and clinical applications how it
effects eventually like you showed some
of the the data which is going to be
published pretty soon in some of the you
know journals so yeah that's good I mean
like it those are the questions I had
when you went through the all these
certain elation and all those things oh
I have a couple of questions like looks
like this enzyme like trance
is kind of like really critical in doing
all these things yeah so is there any
data or literature to show that that is
kind of life affected in certain
disorders neuropsychiatric disorder yeah
so so so this this virtually in the
tissue transglutaminase - is a really
complicated enzyme so you know of course
it can do this it can transaminase
proteins
it also can deaminate so we can convert
glutamine stew glutamic acids yeah and
most importantly I think physiologically
cross-linked proteins across limbs
glutamine and lysines and it's very is
critically important for apoptosis so
this is why actually in studies where
we've tried to knock out TG - it's a
problem because it kills the cells you
can't do it now having said that TG - is
implicated in a variety of disorders of
course it is the auto antigen and celiac
disease which is kind of interesting but
I think in terms of neuronal disorders
most of us have been focused on neuro
degeneration
so there are links between TG to
mutations and Parkinson's disease which
could be interesting given modem
emulation it's certainly involved
there's some implications and beta
amyloid plaque production so yeah it's
implicating a lot but it's a really hard
in time to study and the other thing
about it is it's a very promiscuous
enzyme so we've had a really hard time
trying to figure out how it takes what
its substrates are going to be because
it doesn't just mono immediately
everything monomino a certain things and
so again in Tom Mears lab they've done
some beautiful work alanine scans and so
forth and they've shown that it is long
as the glutamine is there it doesn't
care what's around it basically so so
yeah I mean it's just it's one of these
interesting things I suspect that it's
probably another complex that causes it
to get recruited at certain places but
again we have a lot of work to do to
figure out what it's actually doing yeah
okay and other question is like again
like with all these neural degenerative
disorders you have oxidative stress and
all oh and you're a dopamine serotonin
they might be in terms of they can be
easily oxidized or this thing so how
does that play like I mean like you have
the serotonin in there like attached to
the glutamine and all those things
does cells oxidative state changes like
when you at ion or something like that
does it change the yeah that's a good
question I mean you know I mean for the
for the nuclear pool then one thing to
keep in mind is the the nucleus is a
highly reduced environment and the
monoamine oxidase is don't exist in the
nucleus so I think if the serotonin can
get there it's somewhat safe or the
dopamine can get there it's somewhat
safe the big question I have is you know
we're talking about a postsynaptic
neuron showing these marks which we do
have data for how does that work because
let's say that it comes in through the
synapse how does it get to the nucleus
without being completely destroyed and
and this we just don't know yet we still
I have a feeling that there's going to
be a carrier molecule kind of like with
Kim Chi su gamma and calmodulin then
maybe there's something that can
sequester and protect these molecules on
their way to the nucleus but at this
point yeah we we don't know we don't
know about that we are starting we have
we've just established a nice
collaboration with Vivian LaBrie
advantange I'll to start looking at
parkinsonian tissues and so hopefully
we'll start to get an idea in the
context of neurodegenerative disease
what's actually happening with these
with these marks as well I think that's
about it I think
ank that thank you very much I
appreciate your time and effort and this
will be online pretty soon within the
next 24 hours like you can see I'll send
you a link to okay so again thank you
very much it is really inspiring work
and I look forward to seeing more of
your stuff in the renowned journals
happy to do it good luck again all right
thank you so much thank you